tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovi
che sono la vj ed oggi siamo su the
impossible j circa 45 anni fa non mi
ricordo bene abbiamo scoperto questo
gioco sulla i churros l'ipod è stato uno
dei primissimi giochi impossibili che
quasi nessuno riusciva a fare perché è
una roba impossibile io mi ero messo un
casinò a farlo fino ad impazzire
praticamente il secolo che non lo faccio
vino mi ricordo più una sega scoperta è
uscito per pc e quindi volevo
assolutamente di provare per vedere se
ci riuscivo di nuovo cosa impossibile
però ci provo lo stesso
praticamente è un casino io ve lo spiego
perché è più o meno lo so sto cliccando
io non è che sto non è un video quindi
se ci riesco a primo colpo non trovate
scuse aria mente tengo il moscosi perché
fa figo alimenti è un gioco dove bisogna
saltare i triangolini porca [ __ ] ok
cambiati
ho detto cazzate ma vabbè da reparti
riscassi dovrei riuscirci senza problemi
col mouse così fantastico da poi ci
giocavo tipo quando ogni momenti morti
ovvero al cesso devo far vedere ma oggi
mi sembra che hanno un gioco io ma sono
io che ci siamo regalati ci siamo sotto
ce la possiamo fare
attaccata alla sua memoria legata guarda
che roba
ma avevo averlo trovato e un cazzo di
giocatore che utilizza guardare voi
in effetti lo è meglio se guardavo
perché aspetta un attimo voglio provare
una sfida epica se ci riesco ad occhi
chiusi è impossibile non ci provo
qualche a [ __ ] troppo no ragazzi stavo
riesce stavo facendo cose epica dai
party scalzi sta cosa nota
adesso adesso lo finisco giuro d'accordo
ragazzi scommessa volta è quella giusta
potete iniziare a fare le scommesse tipo
possiamo scommettere non so quello che
volete agosto braccio la gamba al cane
quello chiama lettere che l'altro lo
stesso incrocio scommettete che avete
perso perché stavolta vinco io
la prossima 3 2 1 la musica mi gasa
troppo in chiaro mi ricordo più una sera
gara è da quattro anni che non cito che
avete pazienza non sto cercando di
trovare scuse davvero ok ok possiamo
fare possiamo fare grande ok
sì sì sì poi tira troppo fa parte cazzo
non so non mi ricordo più però è stato
ucciso sorella affanculo sentita non
riesco a giocare col mouse così lo
abbasso perché non si può diciamo che
sono un po arrugginito lega ma è normale
vabbè dopo secoli che non ci gioco è
normale che poi mi avete consigliato
tantissimo geometri dash che similissimo
ecco quello effettivamente è leggermente
più difficile di questo però quello se
vi piace se vi piace questo lo farò a me
fa cagare
ok non era arrivato fino a sto punto
prima salvezza mentale calamità mentale
scusate la sorella a cui poi mi sono
salvato ragazzi hanno sbagliato a
cliccare mi sono salvato per culo ve lo
dico ok se la finta in realtà non preso
il triangolo non so perché non mi ha
ucciso ma va bene così si ok ragazzi ci
siamo ci siamo
[Musica]
sto facendo si si regga su no no no
[ __ ] dico sempre stavolta è buona
poi faccio una figura di merda non
impari non dico niente stavolta ok va al
ma ci vuole calma e favi freddo in tutti
i sensi
sì sì ok abbiamo fatto appoggiarmi a
fatta
bene siamo al 42esimo tentativo solo e
non è tanto tutto fare altre cose invece
si si si lega si regala il me non me ne
frega un cazzo tutta la troika [ __ ]
possono già detto [ __ ]
[Musica]
la gara si si
non so neanche come cazzo ho fatto ma va
bene così e stato un miracolo non fatemi
domande non so come ho fatto a
ricordarmelo ma meglio così faccio
l'altro lo verde che sempre a livello 1
pre diverso non so perche il brit e
ragazzi questa sempre stato più facile
quindi dovrà riuscirci stupito in teoria
dopo un cazzo in spera di riuscirci nel
frattempo posso anche non guardare ma
perché mi ricordo che sta parte basta
tenere premuto in questa invece nota
carica ma perché non riesco a ho capito
dove sbaglio quindi se magari esca a
saltare un secondo prima lo prendo il
cubo classico no no no no no tua sorella
del morire o di atroci che non ho mai
capito come mai una volta che sbaglio
continua a sbagliare sempre nello stesso
punto stavolta no ok ok ho fatto ha
pregato calmi bene bene così bene così
cosa sto facendo mi ricordo più
infatti non mi ricordavo più un cazzo
non ero arrivato fino all è a caso a
casa come ricordo ragazzi non mi sto
ricordando fino a sega sto andando
completamente a caso si è morta di culo
[Musica]
a me biscotti ora e belle donne a
livello che da piccolo mi vantavo
talmente tanto tipo che andavo dalle
ragazze ray sono figo io ho finito e il
prossimo 20 maggio uscire insieme ceo
rimorchiato così anche su però era di
questo non l'ho mai finito non riuscite
a fare un cazzo visto livello però è
bellissima la musica quindi va bene
adesso io la porta è [ __ ] ragazzi
preparatevi
[Musica]
se poi non lo so fare inutile che faccio
figo perché non so fare un cazzo però va
bene ok facciamo tutto il record che
avevo fatto la piccola perché fin lì non
ce l'ho mai arrivato adesso la stelletta
377 cosa da fare quando non si sa che
cazzo fare ok
cosa cazzo ha fatto
riga regala sa che sto facendo io non
sono mai arrivato fin qua giù l'ho mai a
caso no no [ __ ] poi triangolini di
merda e un bug the impossible game ha
smesso di funzionare
no no non è uno scherzo vero e grande
ragazzini che posso concludere qui il
video sarà un piacere di tornare a
giocare a questi giochi giuro
veramente mi hanno regalato emozioni che
non ricordavo da tempo un'interrogazione
che per oggi possono includere qui se il
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovata
nella descrizione se non si dovresti il
discreto io ci vediamo al prossimo vi do
bella ragazzi